la question qui en veut une fois de plus
à Mathieu Delormeau pour Isa c'est moi
vous n'avez pas dit tout à l'heure
avec toi peut-être dans le la mémoire
comment ça un petit peu on l'a reçu deux
mois mais on les trahi par les gens
quand ça il est fâché il est fâché
depuis quand mais je ne sais pas je
découvre les gens qui m'aiment pas
regardez et pourquoi
le truc qui va partir à partir du moment
où tu annonces que tu souhaites me
produire ce qui serait bien c'est que tu
m'appelles en fait parce que depuis je
suis passé dans l'émission il y a
maintenant trois quatre mois plus de 100
plus d'images ah plus de 100 plus images
donc Mathieu Delormeau je vais faire une
rime c'est un mytho on peut pas annoncer
dans une émission people exemple Pascal
son émission moi je l'adore ok merci
c'est gentil de le dire mais je vais te
produire d'accord soit on assume
derrière en disant bah non on sait pas
entendu on va peut-être que c'est
peut-être ce qui va dire non c'est pas
entendu une autre d'argent pour
l'instant j'ai rien demandé d'accord il
n'a pas discuté on ne s'est pas vu
d'accord on n'a pas parlé concept
vous me dites quand je suis de retour à
l'antenne
mais si tu dis des choses je dis des
choses alors Pascal le grand frère
qu'effectivement j'adore parce qu'elle
le grand frère jouer à lancer j'avais
d'autres projets avec lui et je lui dis
est-ce que tu es ok pour que je te
produise parce qu'il a plus d'excus avec
Julien Courbet qu'il avait il me dit oui
bien sûr après Pascal il y a autre chose
c'est que quand on veut produire une
émission on a une idée puis on essaie
d'aller la vendre à une chaîne pour que
la chaîne donne de l'argent et qu'on la
produise si aucun diffuseur ne la veux
c'est un peu qu'on et pour l'instant je
me bats mais pour l'instant pour te dire
la vérité tu es parti tu as dit un peu
de mal de TF1 du coup TF1 ne veut plus
de toi NRJ12 pour l'instant ils veulent
pas c'est vite pour l'instant ils
veulent pas pardon c'est pas que je te
rappelle pas c'est que pour l'instant je
n'arrive pas à te vendre
je n'arrive pas à te vendre sinon
crois-moi que je le ferai donc tu es un
peu de dire que je suis un mytho je suis
pas un mytho je fais des rendez-vous
j'obtiens
tu vois comment c'est
bon on y arrivera Pascal pour le coup je
reste persuadé que ce type c'est un
véritable concept qu'on va le revoir
je t'aime